foreign
people welcome to another live episode
of honest trailer commentaries coming to
you from the future but also the past
compared to this movie Demolition Man a
film that takes place nine years when's
2032 from now I can't do math yeah about
nine years nine years nine years from
now and boy are we there already uh
hello hello lawn hello Danielle Let's uh
we're gonna watch a trailer today we're
gonna uh take your comments and
questions to put those in the chat and
show you some deleted scenes and then
tease you with next week's episode
um this is a fun one mostly seashell
related but there's other things to say
about the film uh I think this movie's
still great what do you what do you guys
think
I love this movie
um all this did was to remind me that I
didn't like own a version of this movie
and so then I went and bought a version
of this movie and it made me really
happy um yeah this one is one of my
favorites it's um
you know it's got that
uh glorious early 90s trying to be the
future and decide what that is and what
that usually just means is like
metal
um yeah no it's it's fantastic uh
Stallone is incredibly amazingly
Charming on this like they really like
amped up his charmingness this is
basically just like two and a half hours
of
um
you know uh uh
great attempts at like trying to uh
establish a catchphrase because like in
every scene there's at least like five
or six different things that could have
been the movies like catchphrase and I
know that that's like it feels very much
on purpose
um yeah I could just live in this movie
forever it's like the perfect dinner
it's like the perfect movie for me I I
enjoyed it I still I still hope there
are cats they're cats currently like
attacking my legs so I'm trying to talk
about this
aren't we all yeah a lot what'd you
think uh yeah I
I don't
I don't one thing I felt like coming as
a modern viewer that it's been
it's been I've watched it is like we
we're constantly in this cycle of like
PC code like
progressives or liberals come along and
introduce some new cultural thing that
makes people upset and then we've got
the regressive cycle of like oh
everything's too woke everything's too
PC and it's just like this endless cycle
and I don't really think about it that
way but this movie really because it's
from the 90s run of like everything's
two PC and you can't be a real man
anymore and you're not allowed to make
jokes anymore and it's just like we're
back in another one of those Cycles
again and it's just like oh it's
exhausting to watch something that's 30
years old and people are doing the exact
same cultural critique that they're
doing right now and pretending that it
somehow relevant you know like this is
the equivalent of a comedy album called
triggered where a guy
you know like it's just that it's just
that again I'm like sure okay and and
the thing is I don't mean this to be
like Demolition Man sucks because it
doesn't it's funny it's clever uh
Stallone and Bullock and Snipes are all
bringing ten thousand percent they're
all it's this is among my favorite
performers is from all three of them uh
so I really like the movie but it did
kind of put me in this mindset of like
wow we're just never gonna get away from
this endless pendulum swing of like hey
you know what it would be nice not to
use this slur anymore oh I'm not allowed
to make the joke ever again you know
like it's just we're endlessly gonna go
back and forth forever it kind of remind
me of like that that period in uh that
period in like the mid mid 90s
um Comedy Central where all they played
was reruns of PCU like that's obviously
the one the part that super drove it
home Dennis Leary who plays the like
disaffected guy who leads the sewer
people and like protests against the
Utopia fake Utopia uh he has a rant
that's obviously it was like a 90s a
Dennis Leary bit like that's what what
his comedy was where he was like the
chain smoking like let me tell you
something I'm going to tell you
something else I'm gonna give it to you
so you know but it just
three three angry YouTube dude today
like it's not substantially different
from any of the anti-worksters today
the reason didn't it didn't bother me I
guess as much is because to me every
film of that era has that same ethos and
is coming from that same political
yeah like you the cops are too chicken
we need a bigger cup to shoot everyone
to finally have the guts to kill more
people and it's like that's that's the
driving force behind like Cobra behind
like every Stallone movie uh save for
maybe Rocky where he's more of an
underdog um or an every man but it's
always about that stuff we need a bad
enough dude like ninjas have kidnapped
the president we need a bad enough dude
to rescue them it does that stuff but
it's more than like getting fine for
saying ass or you're not allowed to eat
a burger anymore or you know like oh
they made society so neat and clean and
tidy that I can't be a real man anymore
like you've outlawed authenticity and
it's like
um all right let's let's roll into our
uh arms trailer or Demolition Man
[Music]
from the same writer as Heathers and
Batman Returns and the director of this
and only this because how could you top
it come Sylvester Stallone's best
dystopian
I didn't correct this in the trailer
because the joke plays better he did
technically make one other mainstream
Studio film oh he did yeah access
baggage I had noted this in the original
note he also made 1997's excess baggage
before retiring I'm not familiar with
that oh with Alicia Silverstone and uh
Benicio del Toro yeah because she's like
a runaway heiress or something exactly
and he and like it winds up being that
he like pretends he kidnapped her so
they could get like
um uh Ransom from her parents but they
fall in love that's Bradford you just
nailed that description of the plug
access baggage uh but anyway what a hot
90s cast yeah he did those two and now
he's a
the video artist yes exactly
that's great uh all right keep going
action comedy since the one that started
his career Italian Stallion
rated X
Demolition Man
travel to the 2030s a conservative's
dream of the future liberals wand you
are an incredible incredibly sensitive
man who inspires joy joy feelings in all
those around you Sylvester Stallone is
the Demolition Man John Spartan an LA
cop with a reputation for blowing things
up like I said an LA cop LAPD Chief
Michael Moore said sorry for the botched
detonation
when he sent to cryo prison for a crime
he did commit the future will turn to
this unfrozen caveman detective to bring
his rival to Justice because in the
Ironclad logic of movies it takes crazy
to fight crazy send a maniac to catch
one Simon Phoenix is an old-fashioned
criminal we need an old-fashioned cop
I'm not sure he's any different than
Simon Phoenix himself send a maniac to
catch me hey you used that one already
Snipes is Simon Phoenix
what the [ __ ] is that thing you are
buying one credit
[Music]
I can't say what about oh wait YouTube
would fit right in and Demolition Man so
pause I heard I heard that here's the
new algorithm is like you can curse
after a certain amount of time it's like
it's like the first 90 seconds right I
think it's a 90 oh I didn't think it was
that high I should probably should have
checked um oh I thought I thought that's
what I read that it's the person 90
seconds of me if you curse it there then
there then then you're a bad person but
if you wait till two and a half minutes
then you're fine that's great so yeah
the kids have gone to bed AI or whatever
the kids have lost uh their attention
spans so short they just click away
after 90 seconds 90 second hand they
can't hang okay got it so yeah now we
can I felt like enough time had passed
we could start um cursing and who knows
who knows that's the things it changes
all the time people like why did you
bleep this why did you bleep that
because like why if they flag it for
language then it doesn't get recommended
to anybody that's why so whoops uh so
we'll just bleep everything
um that you couldn't say in a uh and
these days a g movie like we can PG-13
gets an F-bomb um so we gotta keep a g
here we keep it g that's uh that's the
new slogan we are the top G's I hear the
position of top G is open so we'd like
to assume that yeah
for top G
um hi um
America's Next Top G yeah you will not
be the top G please move out of the G
house
hand in your your D and yellow belt yes
yeah and your fake Rolex okay keep going
is Simon Phoenix a super power terrorist
so over the top he gave Dennis Rodman
whatever his whole deal was Dennis goes
to San Antonio and then Demolition Man
comes out and he changes his hair color
did you know they offered the role to
Jackie Chan first that would have been
different
also never play that clip again
totally forgotten about that beat it's
out of nowhere I mean not out of nowhere
but he's uh I mean it seems wildly
unnecessary yeah like two Wesley to
defend Wesley Snipes momentarily like
obviously the instruction for the entire
film was just be CR you're a cartoon
character be super crazy the whole time
so when you're just being crazy all the
time you know who knows what's gonna
come out and it's the early 90s but yeah
today I think we would have probably uh
not included that I can't really feather
I mean he's so he's such a good foil
um and great part of this movie but like
I also think a Jackie Chan version of
Demolition Man would be amazing although
there's no way Stallone could hang in
like a martial arts format right I just
feels more like Jackie Chan would be the
he would be the the Demolition Man right
like why he would be in the John Spartan
character not the the Simon Phoenix
character to me like I don't know I'm
trying to figure out has he done any big
uh maybe in his uh overseas stuff but
has he ever done like a big villain role
in like a major major Club it's not like
a crazy maniacal Village yeah yeah like
that's the part that would be missing
um I I want to say that maybe in one of
the musicals he did he was like the bad
guy but I guess that probably doesn't
count he probably has been the bad guy
in at least one or two I think it may be
in in who am I maybe he found out that
he was a bad guy before he forgot yeah
he's always the good guy in those movies
like in those classic Jackie Chan movies
he's the super cop you know yeah it's a
police story
um all right uh keep going
Sandra Bullock shines in a breakthrough
role as Huxley she's an adorable little
sociopath we're doing battle with that
strangely weapon scrapped in those
roundhouse quickly look this isn't the
wild west okay hurting people's not a
good thing who learned all of her
English from watching porn you really
really and Dennis Leary
who else thought that I forgot that this
scene existed in the movie
um where he talks about his daughter
being unfrozen and he's gonna go visit
her but he doesn't want to there was
going to be a subplot about the the
daughter I think that that was going to
be Huck's do we think that was going to
be Sandra Bullock I don't I don't think
it was because I know we had talked
about that that like it seems like
they're leaning into she's gonna be his
daughter he's going to discover she was
his daughter after all but no I think
there was another version of the script
where they just explored that more like
he tried to meet back up with his
daughter and then they were like ah this
is too dramatic it's just kind of like
not the vibe that the movie ended up
being yeah
yeah the movie where uh Wesley Snipes is
just doing a black version of Duke Nukem
is it yeah this is a weird fit to do a
father's gentle father daughter but do
it in like a I'm thinking it's more like
the end of Greece where you know this uh
Sandy Sandra shows up at the end but in
like you know the full leathers and
she's like I'm 80s now
[Laughter]
uh and it's room for a sequel God damn
it I I'm sorry to say but the the search
for Spartan's daughter is definitely um
God just don't make it gritty just don't
make it gritty all right anyways we'll
talk about that later keep going oh as
every bumper sticker on the back of a
lifted pickup truck in a Bass Pro Shop
parking lot I don't need bacon and
butter and buckets of cheese okay I want
to smoke two bits of God the size of
Cincinnati in a non-smoking section I
want to run through the streets naked
with green Jello all over my body yeah
this guy is definitely not vaxed even
after AIDS got its own Multiverse after
AIDS there was NRS after NRS there was
ubt so travel to a horrifying vision of
the future not because it's oppressive
that's every dystopia no because
everyone is basic
the dogs
in one of the few R-rated action sci-fi
films that's remembered more for its
clever writing than its shootouts but
kids today will never understand the
significance of this movie just like my
ex-wife will never understand the
significance of the John Spartan
mannequin I bought from a Planet
Hollywood estate sale
it's beautiful
Story
Time cop Blade Runner 2032 she smells
seashells elrond Dullard I want him
bound not tomorrow not after breakfast
now Law and Order San Angelos
Dennis the Menace of the minion and
Netflix Executives Jeffrey Dahmer I love
jacked to the Future
all right uh damn three shots
we're gonna talk seashells um I think
that if anybody has their own
alternative
um seashell Theory now is the time to
put it in the chat and yeah uh we'll
talk we'll talk about those after we uh
while we play our our speculation so uh
go ahead and play yeah
oh you can run our um
okay three seashells time my first
theory is that it's just a bidet control
show one adjust the aim shell two for
water pressure shell three for hot or
cold Theory two is that everyone plugs
or simply scrapes their butts with the
seashells and throws them down the
toilet when they're full this is
supported by a 2006 interview with
Stallone and does explain the presence
of the Chrome plunger-like device to the
right of the toilet likely for ramming
the used shells down the drain a
complicating factor for these theories
however is the presence of the scraps
community in the LA sewer system these
are densely populated neighborhoods
large enough to support multiple food
vendors inside what used to be San
Angelo's sewer meaning that the largest
sewage in water mains of the city are no
longer required for human waste poop
doesn't appear to even make it
underground in this future leading Simon
Phoenix to remark in the underground's
comforting home-cooked smell love that
smell
so where does the poop of San Angelos go
how do the three seashells really work
Demolition Man remains intentionally
obscure on those questions bringing me
to my third and I believe most
thematically consistent Theory nobody
knows how the three seashells work in
universe or out and they're all too
ashamed and repressed to ask each other
for help just listen to Rob Schneider's
reaction here he doesn't know how to use
the three seashells
when it comes with the laugh of a man
who knows how the 3C shells work
Cassandra Bullock a student of our era
and way of life you've done even the
most basic knowledge of how to use the
toilet no why because she doesn't know
either no one knows they're all
funneling around in their shared secret
chain that's why they never touch each
other they all have doodoo hands 34
every restaurant has Taco Bell so all
they do is pee out their butthole anyway
and scene
um so yeah that I think is that pretty
much covers everything we came up with
is there anything that didn't make it in
that we've thought of could be a could
be a feasible answer no I'm a long time
subscriber to uh to poo fingers theory
that I'm I'm a seashell truth that none
of them know none of them know how to
use the shells I don't know yeah I know
I sent you that that extra it's like the
the screenwriter called his friend
um right I need like people just give me
future stuff and he's like I'm on the
toilet I don't want to talk about this
right now it's like it was a great thing
it's the great screenwriter uh Larry
karazewski is the friend that he called
the guy who co-writes uh like all those
great biopics of people versus O.J
Simpson Ed Wood people versus Larry
Flynt Dolomite is my name that
screenwriter came up with the seashells
inadvertently and gave the idea away to
the Demolition Man writer right
um so yeah that's uh that's the origin
story that uh and he also says like
nobody's nobody knows how it works but I
love seeing all the speculation so right
uh in honor of keeping that going sorry
I was just uh reading through some of
your responses
um let's see so Jimmy Robertson says I'm
a theory too um but my question is what
if you need more than three seashells
well they they cover you they cover you
up
um Liz nobody uses the shells it's just
aesthetic and everyone wipes with their
hands see that's what I'm saying that's
exactly thank you it is just aesthetic
um
yeah because I feel like I you know I
feel like Nigel Hawthorne was like we're
going to use shows and everybody just
went along with it and never questioned
I really like a warrior fella bringing
this back uh John Spartan cared more
about the seashells than his daughter's
whereabouts like at the end his final
question is like now how do I wipe my
ass
he finds out he finds out like he wakes
up and they're like he had a wife and
they're like yeah your wife is like long
dead she died you know years ago the big
earthquake yeah the big earthquake and
then like it's what later on that day
the next day that he's like starting a
sexual relationship with his new partner
at work which is like several weird
taboos in one like be a little bit of a
grieving process Jones pardon yeah he
grieved when he was on Ice well right he
was awake so I guess that Daniel Daniel
Salas the seashells are controlled for a
poop incinerator I didn't think about
fire but that would explain why there's
no poop in the sewers it just gets burnt
to a crisp right there nice uh Michael G
Muntz the seashell summon a man person
who cleans your bum oh geez and
determines the intensity of the cleaning
and therefore but that is like the
scraps could like come up from the
sewers and clean your ass for you okay
here's what I want I want to clean your
butthole I'm gonna make it nice I'm
gonna make it shiny it's gonna be
squeaky clean you're not gonna have to
shower after this and that's what all I
want is five cents in return yeah just
it just that doesn't feel very good
consent wise though I don't know lots of
disturbing elements yeah multi-forum
says it's a variation on the Classic
Shell game
um it's not politically correct prefer
one worm of white form of wiping over
the other so you randomly get either
bidet toilet paper or live kitten so
yeah it's like kind of a game oh it's
like three cards I got it okay yeah
um
all right I think that I think that's
everything
did you know that those two guys in
addition to all the great legendary
biopics also wrote The Problem Child
movies I did not realize that until just
now anyway that's great continue uh
Crazy Chris says the first shells for
scratching an itchy butt the second for
getting out the poop and the third is
for the remnants thank you my favorite
HBO series
[Laughter]
well that's
it's like Harry Potter they just magic
in a way yeah it's movie Magic folks
that's what happens to your poop movie
Magic of Cinema yeah
uh let's see if we have any uh I deleted
scenes come Sylvester Stallone's best
dystopian action comedy since the one
that started his career Italian Stallion
rated X come on the other one
Demolition Man
where the woke mob tells you what you
can't say politicians tell you what you
can't put in your body and the Neutered
cops can't even kill people to get the
job done we're police officers we're not
trying to handle this kind of violence
said the maniac to catch a maniac hey
you used that one already in a rare film
that's in full agreement that all cops
are
but they mean it in the best way
possible
[Music]
Spartan Rambo cop blade Infinity newer
Jack City only 90s kids will get this
Sandra's bollocks presidents no job
Judas law the brat pack I don't like
sand Shaggy hobo with a flare pistol
Grand Theft Auto
the PC police
white man time job
the warden of the Phoenix
Grudge dread
all right sweet here you have it
um okay let's get into some of the
non-poop related questions
um yeah I guess we have to Dyson
psychoras Demolition Man versus Judge
Dread versus Robocop who's the better
cop and also are there any other options
I guess like who do you prefer being
pulled over by
terrible terrible cup murdering people
left and right just like a real corrupt
system there uh not into Mega City ones
dispensing of Justice at all so I think
he's out
Demolition Man and versus Robocop I
think John Spartan's not gonna really
give it to me an honest hard-working
citizen but he might he might I don't
know he might kill me
RoboCop sort of shifts during yeah he's
having a little bit of a life crisis
during the movie so it depends on the
beginning of Robocop or the end of
Robocop I think right
yeah I mean what what Kick-Ass movie cop
would you be most okay with getting
pulled over by like feel feel okay about
like all right I'm not gonna die there's
none I I don't I don't want the one that
has to eat baby food that's just a
preference I don't want to be pulled
over by the one who can only handle
eating baby food maybe a uh Jay Leno in
um what's that movie with um with Pat
Morita
I was gonna say uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
as the Kindergarten Cop yeah that'd be
good he's good he's good with people
he's got patience he's got people skills
yeah
um all right uh what else what else
should we talk about I would just be
like I'm sorry I'm driving so
erratically it could be a tumor
uh Jim one said what did the movie
predict the best for you for me it was
the self-driving electric car blowing
uh there is a seed where Nigel Hawthorne
is having a meeting and everybody is on
these like telepresence robots that like
to turn towards him when he speaks and
it's like oh Zoom they called Zoom they
just like this is just zoom we finally
got there
um I think something they didn't predict
um which I thought was funny is a a
LaserDisc LaserDisc is sticking around
in there
oh and then also too they've got mini
discs also I feel like every uh more
than one movie did this predicting
Schwarzenegger as a politician he must
have just been talking to all of his
friends about his plans yeah around then
because it happened by President
Schwarzenegger I think it was the rate
coming out of the Reagan Era it was like
okay actor becomes president who's the
current actor who's gonna be the next
president and being funny about it too
because he's not from America he's got
the accent and you know uh yeah I love
this from uh Luis Valenzuela uh lets us
know after
um oh actually that's a different one
this is sorry sorry uh James Blunt below
you are you aware that the winner of
fast food Wars is different by region in
Europe it was Pizza Hut because Taco
Bell wasn't much of a thing there so the
European version of Demolition Man
there's no Taco Bells in France they're
both they're both young Brands so it was
one company and then they just used
whichever their local fast food chain
was the most popular that's yeah
fascinating
the futuristic Taco Bell in Pizza Hut
the one other interesting thing that
they they sort of called uh was like
commercials becoming as popular as
content like I was thinking about that
just today because we were all like men
do three trailer and like how different
is that really from a commercial turn
that up I want to hear the Oscar Meyer
Channel yeah play that again play that
back play that commentary back
um I think that's enough everything else
is about poop and we covered that pretty
well
um
yeah we're covered in poop
um let's see for next week we're going
to
um
it'll be a film that takes place in
another
situation where it can be difficult to
poop but but certainly possible and
welcome but if there's someone else on
this vehicle with you you're not gonna
feel comfortable uh um relieving your
bowels that's the worst clue we've ever
had usually it's too easy I feel like we
should give them one that they are it's
a real thinker and I think I mean I'll
just uh ramble for uh and they'll have
to figure out what I mean
um but next week all will become clear
um four on Australia commentaries thank
you so much for joining us this time
we'll be back in studio next week
fingers crossed bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]